la parole est à notre collègue françois
pilée pour le groupe l'est républicain
mais la parole monsieur le président
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse le
secrétaire d'état chargé des relations
avec le parlement sur le secrétaire
d'état lors de la présentation de ses
voeux aux corps constitués le président
de la république évoqué le problème de
la lenteur législatives comme notre
collègue philippe bâle a fait observer
dans une lettre au chef de l'état
quelques éclaircissements s'imposent
même si chacun doit prendre devant ce
constat sa part de responsabilité nous
sommes soumis par votre gouvernement une
inflation législative qui nous paraît
sans précédent nous sommes sommés de
nous exprimer sur des textes dont la
surcharge et la complexité dénoncent la
précipitation dans laquelle ils ont été
imaginés ce fut le cas par exemple de la
loi de transition énergétique avec ses
215 article outre l'inflation
législative engendrés par vos
initiatives vous déclarez presque
systématiquement la procédure accélérée
qui paradoxalement participe de la
lenteur législatives dans la mesure où
laisser parfois s'écouler plus de six
mois de délai entre l'examen des textes
par les deux assemblées ce fut le cas de
la fameuse loi
macron qui nonobstant l'article 49-3
aura occupé toute une année de débats le
texte présentant l'origine 106 article
en comptait finalement 300 la lenteur
législatif revient également du fait que
les textes rhétorique implique des
décrets d'application pléthorique et là
encore les délais dépasse la logique
politique concernant cette même loi dite
macron une très large part des 84 décret
d'application sont encore en attente de
publication
monsieur le secrétaire d'état afin que
les parlementaires puissent soutenir au
mieux une action gouvernementale qui
s'inscrit de plus en plus dans l'urgence
ne croyez vous pas que des textes plus
réfléchis donc plus aboutie serait de
nature à accélérer considérablement leur
itinéraire législatif qu'on vous
répondent la parole secrétaire d'état en
charge des relations avec le parlement
il avait la parole monsieur le ministre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur
d'abord nous sommes évidemment tous
concernés aujourd'hui par la réflexion
sur l'efficacité des politiques
publiques et donc parmi ceux-là la
capacité de notre pays à légiférer dans
de très bonnes conditions mais aussi de
façon plus réactif j'en veux pour preuve
d'ailleurs le fait que les deux
assemblées ont réfléchi sur ces
questions a adopté un certain nombre de
mesures et je veux saluer notamment au
niveau du sénat les décisions qui ont
été suggérées par le président larcher
par exemple de rétablir l'article 41
il n'avait jamais été véritablement
appliqué et qui vise effectivement à
alléger le travail parlementaire ce
temps de l'action sans faire donc perdre
de temps et sans perte de qualité au
travail parlementaire doit quand même
continuer à nous faire réfléchir
même si les résultats qui ont été les
nôtres en termes de production
législative ces deux dernières années
sont satisfaisantes la plupart des lois
ont été adoptées effectivement en moins
de 150 jours mais il y a des textes qui
m'aident plus de 300 jours c'est qui est
une question alors que a contrario par
exemple la loi
évidemment marqué par l'urgence je veux
parler de la loi sur l'état d'urgence a
été adoptée évidemment en quelques jours
deux façons comme ceux ci était normal
et attendu par nos concitoyens mais vous
noterez avec moi que un certain nombre
de fonctionnement de nos assemblées ne
correspondent plus véritablement à une
nécessité et parfois même amène et une
certaine forme d'usure du travail
parlementaire
après la réforme de 2008 on a bien vu
qu'il y a toujours une redondance entre
le travail en commission et en session
plénière ce qui a plein d'inconvénients
d'abord sur le temps passé par les uns
et par les autres mais aussi parfois sur
la qualité la spontanéité du débat une
solennité répétitif de ce point de vue
n'est pas positive et donc nous devons
ensemble continuer à réfléchir sur ce à
quoi nous a invité le président la
république en prenant aussi un salon bhr
de sauvegarde
s'agissant de l'inciter de l'action de
la réforme de ce pays
monsieur le ministre monsieur pilée pour
15 secondes
en fait sans vouloir faire polémique ce
n'est ni je constate tout de même que
lorsqu'on compare la durée d'examen des
projets de loi avec la durée
d'élaboration des ordonnances ou des
décrets d'application c'est toujours à
notre avantage
j'observe également que la mise en
oeuvre des réformes dit sociétal qui ont
occupé largement la moitié de la
première moitié du quinquennat du
président de la république ont toutes
trouvé une application quasiment
immédiate alors que les conclusions
d'ordre économique sont encore un peu à
la traîne
merci